as the walking dead slowly works its way
to its inevitable conclusion
after 11 seasons the 10th season episode
find me goes back to the past if you
aren't caught up on the walking dead
there are spoilers ahead dead fans got a
blast to the past in the latest episode
of season 10
which begins with daryl carol and dog
heading out together on a scouting trip
where daryl is confronted by difficult
memories of a very special woman
the episode not only gives fans a look
at what the upcoming daryl and carol
spin-off series might look like but it
also provides a look into the lost years
after rick's disappearance the setup of
the episode is simple enough
carol talks herself into tagging along
with daryl on his expedition which
takes them deep into the woods
surrounding alexandria it's clear that
things
aren't right even though their community
prevailed in the whisperer war
they did so at an incredible cost carol
brings up the destruction of hilltop and
the sacking of alexandria
our luck's run out daryl isn't
in the mood to chat but he's forced to
open up when the pair come across an
abandoned cabin in the woods
while searching the cabin carol finds a
hidden compartment in the floor that
contains some hidden food
and a note written by daryl it's clear
that he has some history with this place
at carol's request he fills her in on
what happened to him there
daryl's story begins during the period
after rick was seemingly killed in a
bridge explosion
we already learned in season 9 that
daryl spent several years after that
event
living in the woods and searching for
any sign of rick this is what we see him
doing and find me
carefully marking locations on a map
he's living in a makeshift
camp and scouring the area for rick's
body when he meets a small
dog who turns out to be none other than
dog
daryl's eventual canine companion they
part ways but dog makes
many trips back to daryl one day dog
runs up to daryl and starts barking for
him to follow
which leads them to an isolated cabin in
the woods with
some walkers inside after daryl
eliminates the threat a woman with a gun
bursts
out of a bedroom she ties daryl up and
interrogates him about who he is and why
he's in her house
once she's convinced that he's not a
genuine threat
she lets him go but makes it clear she
doesn't want to see him on her
property again daryl and the woman
who eventually reveals that her name is
leah begin having a series of run-ins
where one
helps the other but because both of them
are extremely independent
neither seem too happy about it first
leah gives daryl a hand when he finds
himself surrounded by a pack of walkers
only for him to tell her
then daryl catches a fish and leaves it
on leah's porch which she returns
neither can let their guard down long
enough to become vulnerable to the other
that all changes when leah finds daryl
out in the cold and convinces him to
come back to her cabin
while he's there she reveals that it's
her adopted son's birthday and explains
to daryl that she has no
actual family of her own but formed a
close
familial bond with her military squadron
leah tells daryl about the day that a
horde of walkers attacked her group and
she lost her entire adopted family daryl
in turn tells her about rick the knight
of vulnerability softens both of them
and daryl ends up coming to live in
leah's cabin
unfortunately it isn't meant to last
even after daryl moves in with leah he
can't abandon his mission to find
evidence of what happened to rick which
puts a strain on their budding romantic
relationship
leah is clearly someone who has a hard
time letting people into her life
losing her son and her family was a
profoundly traumatic moment
and she had a hard time watching daryl
leave when daryl tells leah he'll be
gone for a few days
she doesn't take that news well where do
you belong daryl
out there in the river looking for your
dead brother day after day after day
or do you belong here with me when daryl
responds that he doesn't
know she challenges him to make a choice
daryl goes on his trip but he has the
revelation that he wants to be with leah
instead
when he returns to the cabin she's gone
and there are no
obvious clues as to what happened to her
he leaves her a note in her secret stash
of food that reads
i belong with you find me this is the
note that carol discovers in the present
day
a sad indication that leah never ended
up returning to her cabin between then
and now
and what happened to her is a mystery
it's not likely that daryl will get a
happy ending with her however
considering daryl and carol have an
entire spin-off series to embark on
while daryl and his relationship with
leah is the primary focus of find me
the episode also puts the spotlight on
daryl and carol's bond
during daryl's long time away in the
woods carol comes to meet with him
multiple times
often expressing worry that their
community is in danger of falling apart
she also tries to gently persuade daryl
to rejoin them in alexandria he
eventually does
but during the flashbacks he mostly
turns a cold shoulder to carol
in the present day when carol tries to
implore
daryl to not blame himself for leah's
disappearance he
lashes out at her he accuses carol of
trying to get him wrapped up in her own
personal issues
carol says that the only thing she's
asking of him
is friendship daryl is pushing carol
away to avoid vulnerability the same as
we saw him do to leah during the
flashback sequences
the difference is that he and carol are
old friends who have been through
a lot together so it's devastating to
see them break down like this
i was right
her looks run out you and me fortunately
there's still plenty of time for carol
and daryl to mend their friendship and
become
the strong resilient duo fans know them
to be
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the walking dead are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
you